mercredi 25 mars monza au nord de milan
l'ensemble du personnel médical de
l'hôpital fann gerardo est sur le pont
prêt à lutter contre le coronavirus une
journée de plus là bas un sas et par la
partie des patients affectés du coc vide
19 du reste de l'hôpital
l'établissement s'est adaptée face à la
crise nous avons commencé avec 25 lits
de soins intensifs
il y à un mois il y avait 25 lits de
soins intensifs et aujourd'hui nous
allons nous retrouver avec près de 100
lits nous devons également considéré que
nous sommes très à travailler et il ya
trois lits pour les soins intensifs
normaux car il ya aussi d'autres
patients le personnel de l'hôpital aide
les patients à se battre contre la
maladie notamment grâce aux ventilateurs
qui fournit de l'oxygène aux malades
malgré un contact quotidien avec des
personnes infectées par le corona virus
le docteur ne craint pas pour sa santé
non non je ne suis pas inquiet ce n'est
pas l'endroit le plus dangereux est
l'endroit le plus dangereux est à
l'extérieur à monza de nombreux patients
affectés du coronavirus arrive à
l'hôpital avec d'autres maladies le
docteur giuseppe faut-il souligner
l'importance d'admettre les personnes
potentiellement touchées par le coït 19
et de les regrouper dans la même unité
de soins ici un patient montre des
signes d'amélioration
il n'est pas complètement réveillé mais
je suis sûr qu'il va se réveiller
complètement au cours des deux premiers
jours mais il est très important de
reconnaître que cela pourrait être un
patient qu'ovide parce que si vous le
mettez dans une unité de soins intensifs
neuro c'est risqué vous pourriez
infectés tous les patients de l'unité de
soins intensifs
la solution du coc vide et d'avoir
l'isolément de tous les patients à
l'intérieur au même endroit les médecins
disent d'accord c'est une pneumonie
peut-être seco vide non c'est une crise
cardiaque paco vide
au lieu de cela nous devons y penser
toujours peut-être et sans passion qu
vide c'est le cas mais il va mieux
le pic de l'épidémie est toujours
attendu l'italie reste le premier pays
européen touché par la pandémie